now yet again the media mob is caught
spreading another round
of completely fake news because remember
you know all the hysterical reckless
coverage
last summer after park police remember
they cleared out protesters near
lafayette square in d.c donald trump he
was accused of removing protesters
for a photo op in front of saint john's
church well just like clockwork it turns
out
that narrative was an utter and complete
lie trump russia that was the lie
ukraine quid pro quo that was joe that
wasn't donald trump
now we were misled about the origins as
we now know
of covid and the wuhan lab on virology
that of course the left-wing media lied
about that
said you know most people it's an
amazing thing most people guilty of
spreading lies
spreading hoaxes and conspiracy theories
they're the ones out there accusing
everyone
else of being guilty of that which they
are
you know practicing daily now tonight
new information
internal watchdog report finding that
park police did not clear demonstrators
for president trump
but instead to install anti-scale
fencing
in response to attacks on federal
property now just listen to the
pain of fake news reporter i guess his
name is can
kendall elaine you know something
whatever from msdnc
having to deliver the news to chucky
todd
who will never be tim russert take a
look
you know the narrative took hold and it
was widely reported across the
mainstream media
that barr ordered this thing to clear
the park for trump and that's not
what happened according to this
independent inspector general report
chuck
yeah park was ordered cleared trump
wanted to go
but the two were not connected that's
basically it seems like what we're
learning with this report all right
bottom line
yeah remember these fake news headlines
last summer
npr peaceful protesters tear gas to
clear the way for trump church photo op
new york toilet paper times quote how
trump's idea for a photo op led to havoc
in a park
you know we often ask and expose what
the media
uh what the mob in the media gets wrong
but the real question
we should be asking do they get anything
right it doesn't seem so
here to react to all of this he is the
host of the number one show sunday night
here
on the fox news channel life liberty
levin now this new book
is coming out in a couple of weeks it's
on hannity.com
it's on amazon.com i have had an
opportunity to read
a number of the chapters this book it
provides the road map to save this
country
it is that profound i call him the great
one mark levin
sir a lot of ground for you to cover
tonight congrats on the book i can't
wait it's in bookstores soon
thank you you're very very kind i need
to spend my
four minutes and 37 seconds on this
because it's important
the media spent the media spent two or
three weeks
lying about donald trump you know what
should we expect really from the
american media it's not the media it's
the democrat party
these people are dressed up as
journalists that's all it is whether
it's cnn or msnbc you saw chuck todd
who has an iq of about a fifth grader he
can't decide what kind of haircut the
guy wants
donald trump is the most abused
president in american history
now let's see what happens here i have
the report
they say protests began in and around
lafayette park on may 29th
may 30th of 2020 the united states
park police and u.s secret service
established a unified command
49 u.s park police were injured and by
the way over
50 secret service were injured the
president and his family had to be taken
to the nuclear bunker
they had to clear the way out to get in
non-climbing fences
you had a historic church that was
burned and these clowns including todd
and his network
talk about a mostly peaceful protest
there's your insurrection baby
there's your incitement for an
insurrection baby now should we be
surprised at the media in this country
no you got to remember
that during the holocaust led by the new
york times they covered up the holocaust
so of course they're gonna
lie about what took place in lafayette
park now let's go down memory lane
joe biden always the ambulance chaser
street politician
about trump he tweets you're using the
american military against the american
people he tear gas
peaceful protesters and fired rubber
bullets
liar joe biden the next day when a
hundred thousand americans died because
of his incompetent leadership
this president goff when americans
peacefully protest outside the white
house
this president teargassed them for a
photo op liar
kamala harris donald trump just tear gas
peaceful protesters for a photo op
liar chuck schumer one of the most
grotesque politicians to ever
walk on two feet on the planet how low
can this president go president trump
ordered federal authorities to fire tk
tear gas on peaceful protesters liar
the next day same thing pelosi same
thing
adam schiff same thing general jim
mattis oh the great general mattis
when i joined the military some 50 years
ago i sworn out to support and defend
the constitution
never did i dream that troops taking
that same oath will be ordered under
any circumstance to violate the
constitutional rights of their fellow
citizens
much less to provide a bizarre photo out
for the elected commander-in-chief
liar general martin dempsey an obama hat
america's military our sons and
daughters it goes on and on and on
the washington compost the new york
slimes
npr the daily beast now you know what
this story that shows them all to be
liars
will last about 30 seconds and then we
go on to tomorrow
and as you were pointing out earlier in
the show sean
they have lied about so much so many
conspiracy theories so many collusions
about donald trump
it is awful i want to take the remaining
two minutes and 17 seconds i have
to say this and i mean this in all
seriousness deadly serious
joe biden because of what he's done with
the pipeline with russia
because he what he's doing with
tick-tock and others with communist
china
the signals he's sending despite his
tough talk
joe biden's going to get us in a war i'm
convinced of this
i'm sad to say he wants to spend six
trillion dollars
he's out of his mind but he wants to
keep flat
defense spending keep flat defense
spending when china is completely out of
control and they're preparing to
invade taiwan that's number one
number two joe biden is going to create
not a recession but at some point of
depression
maybe not on his watch but he's
certainly dragging us down that path
even deutsche bank in the strongest
terms has warned about
unprecedented inflation and i want the
american people to understand what that
means
that means the value of the currency
goes down
the value of your paycheck your pension
your savings
everything goes down but prices go
way way up we saw this early in the
reagan administration we had
two very tough years to try and kill off
inflation
this man joe biden has taken the trump
recovery
and he's turning it into the herbert
hoover franklin roosevelt
depression you better keep an eye on
this guy
folks because it's not that he's out of
his mind
it's that he's out of his league that's
it
american marxism amazon.com hannity.com
life liberty levin every sunday night
8pm right here on the fox news channel
mark levin great one thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else